before we started recording this we're
gonna talk about like how we all met one
this guy was like I don't think Joey
remembers the first time we met I think
I do though okay to read the email that
I said this is why I had but you send it
to me right yeah yeah so this is about
like I must have been like four months
into me doing YouTube and I think I had
like maybe 30 40 K subs
yeah yeah I think Joey I think he had
like nine hundred K at this time
probably it was something like you had a
long yeah I think way more than I had
and so I sent you an email saying that's
just so in for like hello there my name
is Connor Connor or C dot VA on YouTube
hey this doesn't make any sense
grammatically or sit over there on my
ice use commas hello there my name is
Connor or C dog day on YouTube channel
here okay here's where it starts to get
real crazy I've been working on a Levi's
vs. Sebastian rampant okay I'll finish
it the likes yeah yeah
it and it is about 90% complete I
noticed you recently did a rap battle
and it was well done I couldn't have
kissed your ass more here huh it's more
of an insulting each other a character
rap I have the voice of sebastian
michaelis english dubbed down to a tee
wow really wow wow well and i was
wondering if you'd like to be Levi's if
you wish to talk to me more about about
it and the logistics feel free to
contact me on skype I wanted this sound
professional spot yeah or just reply to
this email any responses appreciated
kind regards see don't fees any of use
my real name so you don't be a and then
Jerry replied saying hi there
sure sounds like fun smiley face I had a
do on skype we can talk about it and I
remember the first thing that Jerry sent
me was like yo your voice is cool as
[ __ ] yeah I was like I still think that
so that's how I and she'd say I thought
that was so cool that you actually
replied cuz I'm not gonna lie I'm kind
of mean when I see a video normally when
it's like collab it's normally like
normally it's like I I don't know what I
want to do yet but I want to collab
what do you don't know what you want to
do yeah so that's why I'm a year yeah I
[ __ ] remember that too because yeah
the the rap battle I did was so bad
don't watch it